so we're here with Paul Paul why is it
important to be able to throw away your
prototypes once you've made them I would
say that it's important to throw away
your prototypes because it makes sure
that you're not invested in your
prototypes one of the goals of
prototyping is that all of your
prototypes are cheap and super fast and
so thinking about your prototypes is
throwing them away make sure that you're
going to think about them as these cheap
fast little things that you spit out
quickly get rid of recycle move on
prototype shouldn't be thought of as
just an end into themselves that's one
of the things engineers kind of think
about not insert prototypers for
prototypers prototypes are means to the
end of making good product being able to
use your tests being able to demo
putting together a video for VCS for
example mmm so the end goal is this
prototyping process rather than any
individual step along the way exactly